(audience cheers and applauds)
- It's been an incredible
day getting a chance to host.
I know Kelly always finishes up
with something that she
loves that's trending,
so I'll do the same.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Like I said earlier,
my better half, Jessica
is a super talented singer.
She's been performing
since she was 16 years old.
She is purely heart
and soul, and all mine.
Hmm.
Humble brag, she was also amazing
at last year's GLAAD Awards.
I don't know if y'all saw that.
It was great.
(audience cheers)
This year Jessica dropped a
new single called "We Drip".
I actually directed the music video
and made a little appearance in it.
I am so excited because
she'll be performing
right here in just a moment.
But first,
(audience cheers)
as Kelly always does, I'm liking her post.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Congrats, babe.
Now, before we get to the music,
we've hit the moment in the show
when Kelly usually gives
a guest a thousand dollars
courtesy of her season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of the G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show".
But Jessica and I are doing our way,
so today's cash is gonna go
to someone in the audience.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Look under your seat.
A cheque is taped under one of 'em.
Check under the seat.
(drum rolls)
- [Producer] Look under your seat.
Look under your seat.
(audience screams)
(upbeat music)
- What is your name?
- Hi, my name's Claudia.
- [Niecy] Claudia, how are you gonna use
that money, honey?
- Oh my gosh.
I'm going to Disneyland.
- Oh, hey.
(audience cheers)
Enjoy.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I wanna give a huge thank
to all of our guests today,
Ernie Hudson, Melia
Kreiling, Susie Sarich,
Detective Denise Cookie Bouldin, Genesis,
and that Little Sophia.
Now, without further ado,
get up for Jessica Betts
performing "We Drip".
(audience cheers and applauds)
(slow music)
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Studying your lashes ♪
♪ Kiss the curve above your lip ♪
♪ Get undressed ♪
♪ I intend to know you like
the surface of your skin ♪
♪ We caress ♪
♪ Come near ♪
♪ Woo, yeah ♪
♪ Figures in the moonlight ♪
♪ Loving this view ♪
♪ Soft hips ♪
♪ That dip ♪
♪ I suppose you know ♪
♪ We drip ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ We drip, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
♪ Oh, whoa ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Yeah.
- [Niecy] Come here.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you so much.